qui nous a envoyé spécial de France 24 à
Helson vous êtes personne mais vous
suivez très ce qui se passe dans le
reste du pays à Kief notamment quels
sont les derniers éléments dont vous
disposez
et bien est-ce que l'on sait c'est que
ces attaques elles sont massives et très
largement réparties un peu partout sur
le territoire ukrainien vous l'avez dit
la capitale Kiev a été sous-attaque au
moins trois immeubles ont été touchés
les secours sont sur place et les
autorités ont demandé aux habitants de
rester à l'abri dans les sous-sols mais
hormis la capitale et bien il y a les
frappes russes les tirs de missile russe
on frappait beaucoup d'endroits dont
j'ai Tommy à deux heures de Kiev ou
encore l'hôpital de militaire d'irpine
qui lui aussi a été touché la défense
aérienne ukrainienne elle s'est activée
à nombreux endroits du côté d'Odessa
dans le sud au centre à tiers cassis et
demi pro soumis au nord-est écarquises
comme vous l'avez dit
s'étire de domicile ils ont notamment
visé des infrastructures électriques
d'ailleurs où je me trouve donc non pas
à Carson exactement mais entre Mikola
Yev et Odessa et bien on a plus
d'électricité depuis maintenant une
demi-heure et l'Armée de l'Air
ukrainienne a lavé prévenu elle avait
prévenu en début de semaine que Moscou
stocker des missiles pour renouveler ses
attaques contre l'infrastructure
énergétique ukrainienne qui est déjà
bien mise à mal le pays connaît des
alors vous pouvez entendre autour de moi
apparemment ça a continué aux alentours
ce n'est pas la première fois en tout
cas que l'on voit des infrastructures
civiles être attaqué juste après une
grande défaite militaire russe avait été
le cas au tout début de l'offensive
russe avec la bataille de Kiev et puis
ensuite lorsqu'ils ont perdu quartier
mais maintenant la ville de Kerson qui
était la seule capitale provinciale que
les forces russes avaient réussi à
maîtriser pendant toute l'occupation
donc ça a été une humiliation militaire
pour la Russie et d'ailleurs plusieurs
habitants que l'on a rencontré ces
derniers jours nous informer que et bien
c'était une de leurs craintes que le
ressentiment un ressentiment russe en
fait une espèce d'esprit de revanche qui
pousserait les russe a bombardé
davantage et on se demandait ces
derniers jours qu'elle allait être la
stratégie des forces russes et bien avec
ses cire de missiles massif il
semblerait qu'ils aient choisi la
stratégie de la terreur merci beaucoup
Taline en direct de goblève et surtout
soyez prudent avec le reste de l'équipe